das würde ich heute darauf antworten
sorry du vin obwohl das soll jetzt nicht
heißen dass ich es machen würde
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem wirklich sehr sehr
spontan video
ich probiere heute mal ich fahr mal kurs
angeben mit der kamera ist am
leichtesten ich habe keinen plan wie
lange das dauert
oder ob sie überhaupt klappen wird ich
wollte jetzt nur mal schnell aufnehmen
zumindest dass das video ein bisschen
interessant wird weil wenn es nicht
interessant wird daraus ja auch gar
nicht hochladen ich glaube das gehört
einfach dazu und ich habe es auch schon
von vielen anderen usern halt wenn man
so personen des öffentlichen lebens ist
sondern installierung account hat dem
paar leute folgen dann ist es auch ganz
normal dass ein wirklich so wöchentlich
würde ich das einfach mal sagen
irgendwelche fake-accounts anschreiben
und ich bin so jemand tut es sich bei
jedem hinterher aber manchmal mache ich
mir jetzt schon die mühe und versucht so
ganz groß raus zu bekommen ob das jetzt
ein fake account ist oder ob die person
das was jetzt schreibt halt wirklich
ernst meint wenn ich jetzt aber mal
genau überlege keine ahnung ich würde
sagen wir gehen jetzt einfach mal davon
aus dass im jahr 2018 mich schon 30
accounts also flirty oder notgeil kann
man eigentlich auch schon was sagen
angeschrieben haben und von diesen 30
waren wirklich war
20-25 bestimmt es gibt auf jeden fall
ein paar einfache tricks mit denen man
das raus bekommen trotzdem kamen
wirklich ab und zu ja sehr interessante
nachrichten bei mir an und das was immer
passiert wenn man das ganze auflöst ist
man wird blockiert oder sofort weil die
halter angst bekommen ist ja wirklich
schon wieder postbote ich habe über das
kochen das eine oder andere bestellt wie
man sehen kann ist aber längst nicht
alles also auf jeden fall coole videos
leute ganz wichtig kurze unterbrechung
und zwar weil ich das sagen auf dem kopf
wie youtube kanal gibt es auch ein neues
video von mir trage dass doch im acht
arten von schülern im sportunterricht
ist auf jeden fall 40 geworden man kann
auch wieder was cooles gewinnen lenkt
dann sowohl der video beschreibung schon
auf jeden fall mal vorbei jetzt geht es
weiter hier und jetzt kommen wir auf den
punkt ich habe gerade eine nachricht
bekommen und zwar von einer laura
nicht gerade ist schon ein bisschen her
und sie hat mir etwas sehr nettes
geschrieben und zwar hey süßer und ich
habe mir kurz war das profil angeguckt
und das ist halt wieder so ein fall wo
ich jetzt also eigentlich 100 prozent
sagen kann ok das ist wieder irgendein
geil oder vielleicht auch ein typisch
hat keinen plan der sich die mühe macht
einen account zu erstellen und halt dann
so leute wie mich an schreibt warum auch
immer
wir gehen der sollte mal ein bisschen
auf den grund und schreiben bisschen mit
der person nicht dokumentiert und dann
zeige ich euch am ende mal welchen trick
man benutzen kann um herauszufinden ob
die person fake ist oder nicht er ich
habe jetzt hier mal auf die schnelle
meinen kamera equipment so ein bisschen
aufgebaut habe auch gerade schon
zurückgeschrieben heil ich glaube die
person hat auch schon geantwortet
münchen
ich weiß aufnahme okay also noch mal von
vorne das was wir gerade eigentlich
schon durch hatten sie hat auf jeden
fall auch gerade antwortete kann man es
den hey süße habe ich ganz en detail
finde dich echt heiß bist genau mein typ
so lese ich jeden tag öfter kann man
nicht nur ein spaß ist also solche
nachrichten sind schon keine ahnung also
natürlich kriegt man ab und zu mal so
was was auch wirklich ernst gemeint ist
von zuschauern und so finde ich auch
echt so verleiht aber so halt in diesem
besonderen sind nach genau das ist hier
ihr profil habe ich ja eben aus wie
folgt mir sogar ich könnte auch folgen
laura ist eine bekleidungsmarke
anscheinend ja laura du es gut das
schiff wahrscheinlich für düsseldorf
lauer durch 98 wenn man sich das
profilbild anschaut das sieht ja schon
gar nicht mal schlecht aus also auf mich
ich habe heute wirklich so also sie
kommt aus düsseldorf ich habe hier
cologne stehen vielleicht hat sie sich
selbst extra für mich angepasst beweis
also ohne spaß das ist ein anderes level
diese fake account ich schreibe jetzt
erst mal kurz mit ihr ich weiß nicht ob
ich das aufnehmen weil ich habe schon
gesagt es besteht natürlich die
möglichkeit dass sie halt vielleicht
auch real ist also keine ahnung so gut
wir haben eine antwort und zwar auf
jeden fall jemand bock und zwar zeigt
mir was von dir also ich habe eben schon
gesagt man krieg öfter so nachrichten
oder halt so was in die richtung
deswegen bin ich jetzt gar nicht so
überrascht euch denken sich jetzt halt
welche von what the [ __ ] ich schreibe
einfach mal so wie ich halt ganz normal
schreibe oder soja eigentlich das würde
ich heute darauf antworten sorry du vin
obwohl das soll jetzt nicht heißen dass
ich es machen würde so jetzt hat sie es
gelesen jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was
kommt
sie haben einfach schon wieder ein
postbote so wir haben eine geniale
antwort und zwar kombi nicht mit so was
weiß doch wie ihr jungs tickt und bleibt
unter uns auch so okay wenn das sol sah
mich schreiben von iss und zwar habe ich
jetzt jeder eine tolle nachricht
verfasst und zwar mit schickt du doch
mal weil so das ding ist man kann jetzt
hier halt auch über ins tram kann man ja
fotos denn alles mögliche und vielleicht
von jetzt halt was oder halt nicht wir
warten einfach mal ab 61 stunden später
also kriegt das grad gar nicht mit aber
es ist wirklich sehr anstrengend immer
zu warten und also ich bin ja gerade am
verhandeln und so habe ich geschrieben
geschickt du doch was dann hat sie
geschrieben zeige ich dir danach habe
ich es gerade geschrieben du hast mir
doch geschrieben also ohne spaß wo ist
da der sinn ich schreib doch nicht
irgendwann an verlangen direkt was von
dem besuch ich mir das gemacht hat so
verstehe die leute
wir haben eine neue nach ja das ist auch
irgendwas ganz vernünftiges ding ist
jetzt natürlich nur kann man halt
einfach aus dem internet ziehen ich
würde sagen ich zeige euch jetzt mal
folgendes oder ich versuche es zumindest
weil ich bin mir eigentlich sicher dass
es klappen wird bevor ich jetzt weiter
hier zeit verschwendet ist ja eigentlich
sehr schön und machen wir den absoluten
alex wie fake check
man muss auch sagen es ist sogar ich
finde sowas kann auch spaß machen hätte
ohne witz auf jeden fall so ich habe
geschrieben die hat noch geschrieben ich
mach mal kurz ein screenshot dann muss
hier keine bildschirmaufnahme mehr
machen so und jetzt dann hab ich
geschrieben edu spricht mich nicht so an
und sehe dann irgendwann gefragt ob ich
schwul bin ja dann geschrieben tun nicht
so danach los und irgendwie jetzt gerade
noch ich warte ich wollte jetzt noch mal
drauf schreiben
reisetermin herz gegeben habt ihr noch
dieses haus geschickt so als kleine
abrundung das gespräch ist jetzt machen
wir mal folgendes leute und zwar ich
weiß nicht vielleicht habt ihr damals
schon mal so ein video von mir gesehen
da habe ich das schon mal gezeigt aber
nicht so krass wie das vielleicht könnte
es auch die ein oder andere von euch
aber aber ich glaube die wenigsten
kinder und da gibt es hier nämlich eine
seite die
in punkt de ich habe es genau den namen
eingegeben von ihr und dann wird einem
direkt das bild in groß angezeigt dabei
sonst kann man das ja nur so kleinen
screenshot und also wenn die jetzt wenig
realistisch springen hier gut ist nun
der erste start so jetzt sichern wir das
bild mal kurz und hat jetzt seine zweite
möglichkeit die habe ich euch auch schon
mal erklärt oder gezeigt im gegen dem
video und zwar ist dass die bilder
rückwärtssuche und zwar durch das bild
jetzt die hofladen das wird jetzt wieder
entladen und wird mit allen bildern auf
ganz internets verglichen und in diesem
fall ist es wirklich ein sehr schlechter
fällt eigentlich sogar ich habe schon
fake-accounts gefunden die waren viel
besser aufgestellt und die rhein kann
man auch ganz klar sehen das ist sehr
sehr viele geht oder was wir jetzt viele
aber zumindest einige die auch dieses
foto nutzen um fakes damit zu stellen
wenn man jetzt hier auf die erste seite
geht das ist wahrscheinlich der erste
mal kommen von der original person sogar
das ist wirklich eine richtig dumme die
hat sogar einige follower also über eine
halbe million und auch stumpf einfach
das gleiche profil bildend irgendwo
kostet oder sohn jetzt mache jetzt
folgendes jetzt frage ich sie mal ob sie
so viel heißt oder wie es jetzt so
sophia ich frage die person jetzt ob sie
so viel heißt oder auch viel arbeit ich
schreibe jetzt heißt du eigentlich so
viel weil dann sollte es ja eigentlich
schon so ein bisschen klick machen sie
hat geantwortet warum also weil der
screenshot wie man hier das original
profil
jetzt muss kurz niesen ich habe jetzt
das originale profil gesendet und
eigentlich könnte sie jetzt nichts
anderes machen außer sich er eigentlich
kann sie gar nichts mehr machen also die
person gut man könnte sich jetzt
versuchen rauszureden aber das ergibt in
diesem fall wirklich gar keinen sind
jetzt auch schon gesehen ich schreibe
noch dazu gibt dir mal mehr mühe
ja das war's dann auch schon
ich finde also also ein bisschen feiere
ich mich so auch immer für so was also
jetzt ohne sparen aber irgendwie ist es
auch es ist so es ist einfach so dumm
beide das war das kurze video dazu ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen schreibt auf
jeden fall eure meinung zum thema in die
kommentare würde mich wirklich sehr
interessieren gibt auf jeden fall einen
daumen nach oben
ich habe geschrieben warum
einfach so wie heißt sie laura war nicht
so viel aber eigentlich aber ich weiß es
eigentlich gar nicht mehr